what's up party people welcome to honest
trailer commentaries forward the honest
trailer for bright we talk about the
honest trailer we made for that one go
through it scene by scene if you stick
around to the end you'll see the stuff
that didn't make the cut yeah deleted
crappy stuff I'm Gilbert that's Joestar
that's Dan Merrill hello we had to watch
bright more than once for your
entertainment you're welcome I got well
I I got lucky oh yeah this is I jumped
ahead to do to work on something else
that we've got coming up so I was
largely on the sidelines for this this
was fine you have a seat you guys go
through this well it was tough because
it's a I wouldn't put it in transformers
to category not nothing is like that but
it is just like a dark bummer of a movie
where it's just like it's literally dark
obviously it's cool right very good you
actually can't see what's happening in
most scenes especially if I mean this I
feel like there should have been a
Netflix executive who was like hey more
lights on this maybe people are gonna
watch this on their phone I can't see
these trucks spinning I don't know I
mean yeah and this is like a hundred
million dollar movie or 90 million
dollars or something a lot and like it's
just they spent it on like the
shimmering Jacuzzi makeup yeah yeah yes
so this is Netflix is first but not the
last foray into like things that would
otherwise be big-budget filmmaking yeah
and it shows the same quality control
they've shown towards all the movies
since they're not off to a great movie
star
yeah have their original production arm
yeah they just buy this off the street
like they did Cloverfield like a mmm
like you would they they did the they
did the Times Square method on a
Cloverfield paradox oh you just went up
and just like hey can I can i buy that
from you and they're like here you go
yeah guys now this movie is a little
it's a little whatever but i reaiiy wish
more people had seen mute so that we
could have done mute because mute you
wish mute had been bright had been
oh my god I don't think people even
realize he's Amish in the future that
the movie is about a future Amish man
yeah what honour and the mute see I
didn't see mute the mute man is his
space Amish and he's got a quest for
revenge or to find his lost girlfriend
but all he can do is just hold up the
photo of her and then punch people but
he's not like I'm Amish and I'm mute so
this is like heightened my other senses
he's tough but he's not like anything
he's not like John wick or something
like that is one of the strangest slogs
I've ever been through I worry for
Duncan Jones after moon was so good yeah
but it's been like Warcraft and then
mute is like the work stuff and Warcraft
was good I will I will defend the orcs
to network or versus the work stuff and
bright no just general generally the orc
stuff that anything that was about der
Tann was pretty good just like you know
a human don't every fight will go on
Warcraft Hill about who's got better at
work stuff yeah versus this movie yeah
this is a horrible movie you didn't like
it did you Joe right I thought it was
really weird and conventional like I I
to me this was a movie that certainly
had very high aspirations mm-hmm but it
registered to me as a fairly average
movie in the David Ayer era yeah a
training day and in the watch.watch dark
deep blue or dark blue dark blue yeah
it's just kind of that gritty crime
drama thing but in the script you just
kind of did find and replace and instead
of like you find cocaine and replace
with magic exactly there you go I wager
and I will I will watch my me put on my
crystal ball and predict comments you
guys are taking this movie too seriously
you're just supposed to like turn your
brain off and like watch why can't you
just turn off your brain i watch them
just like shoot stuff it wasn't supposed
to be a great movie and I look they're
not wrong you can turn your brain off in
joy you know paint chips but the the
fact that this was on Netflix I don't
think excuses it I treated this movie as
if I had paid 70 dollars in Los Angeles
to go see it and be like wow that's a
really by-the-book buddy-cop movie but
they replaced all the words with magic
words yeah yeah and then they tried the
really ham-handed like discrimination
subplot main plot the film was just like
let's just I think it's and deleted
scene but like can we stop making movies
where we treat the races as different
species yeah Tokyo where it's like but
they're different species like you're
defeating the point you're trying to
make no I'll still argue that it works
for Zootopia cuz to an extent because
utopia is supposed to be like a fairy
tale for children so like on the surface
if you're trying to talk racism to a -
like a little kid you can talk to them
about the differences between a bunny
and a fox maybe and then as they get
older they go oh now I know what the
bunny and Fox meant but bright is
supposed to be for I don't know whose
bright suppose before I die you just
blew my mind because I did not realize
until you guys just brought it up that
this is like dark Zootopia yes yeah it's
Autopia right ork topia yeah geez it
scene let's roll it yeah oh and for
those that's that I'm predicting
comments too cuz I've already seen it on
Twitter for those that are saying but
you said you couldn't do Netflix things
oh here's the thing we assumed that yes
without ever asking anyone and then we
asked somebody and they said oh we can
yeah just wait a little bit yeah so here
we are we go you're please don't
yes
[Music]
from the director of Suicide Squad the
writer of Victor Frankenstein and
trigger warning entertainment that's a
new about race relations director of
Suicide Squad the writer of Victor
Frankenstein and trigger warning
entertainment fairy lives don't matter
today this is gonna be a bumpy ride huh
right that line improvised by will
commence login to first choice for
prestige television and last choice for
movies to see a film that would have
crushed at the box-office and that's I
say that even going beyond a Netflix
hater I'm not gonna cancel my you know
$8.99 per month thing yeah but like even
outside of their original movies I would
never think to fire up Netflix to go
find a movie like third library is
garbage their library has its raw
declined yeah I remember I mean I'm I'm
so old I used to get DVDs in the mail
from Netflix it's like that's right
associated with is like oh let's rent
movies from there and it's maybe like
the fourth place I would look for
something yeah I'm trying to think the
last time I actually watched a movie
yeah that flicks bright Cloverfield
ain't none yeah not original yeah I'd
almost rather pay six bucks on prime to
rent something then then spend an hour
scrolling through Netflix scroll
endlessly a tear
we're gonna watch point-blank again I
guess yeah but then even Grosse Pointe
blank will be gone and then it will pop
back up that'll disappear and all the
Disney stuff is about to leave yeah when
they get their thing going so there's
movies so they're making a bazillion
original sure 700 700 it's the trailer
will should Netflix lean into the idea
that like a lot of its garbage
just like you guys want to watch
something ridiculous check out the
Christmas prints it's the worst movie
ever made
like should they just lean into it and
be like I don't know you pay someone
this is good I should do it where it's
like the audience is seeing these films
for the first time at the same time
Netflix is seeing them for the first
time like they disavow any knowledge of
it oh they click upload and be like wow
I can't believe we gave him
that to do that yeah that'd be fun side
note I just read this on our way in but
Netflix for their kid stuff they're now
experimenting with giving kids little
digital stickers for watching children's
programming hmm rewarding yeah yeah yeah
so if i watch bright enough times like i
get a cool little orc sticker yes you do
yeah a dork faced at justice like a
shotgun full of like a blue yeah yeah
and that way you'll know whether or not
I'm an internet movie commentator first
or an or worker first Oh getting ahead
of ourselves
sorry let's keep box office if buying a
ticket for the same is something
auto-playing after you pass out during
mine hunter don't lie netflix you think
they will get a movie once yeah those
views don't count hi Texas we walk you
should ever seen ridiculous six yeah
that exactly once and I woke up in the
last whatever minutes and ridiculous six
there's like no props to Kevin and TJ
for that mock-up all right out see Will
Smith like you've never seen him before
not as the wild-card caught with a
by-the-book partner from bad boys or the
wild-card cop with a by-the-book partner
from men in black or the wildcard copper
the by-the-book partner for my robot or
a wild-card soldier with a by-the-book
partner and Independence Day or a one
further by-the-book partner in Wild West
or a wild-card mercenary with a pile of
a partner in Suicide Squad but a
wildcard cop with a by-the-book partner
who's an orc
whoa explore a movie that's boss Scott I
think he could probably do the same
because Will Smith has two types of
movies he has the wildcard cop with a
by-the-book partner movies and then he
has the Oscar movies serious business
movies his serious business movies all
are kind of similar to well but I think
inside the serious business movies you
have the two subcategories which are the
successful serious business movies and
the horrific Lee failed
seriously this movies like collateral
takes a big sweater oh seven pound is
seven pounds which is like whoa but I
think he's playing the same kind of guy
of like the long-suffering depressed
yeah because happiness is sort of the
same guy happiness is yeah very kind of
struggling and seven pounds
spoiler
I love spoiling seven baths I don't only
can't believe it the seven bucks
what fart is your favorite because I'm
thinking of like two of my favorites the
climax of the movie is him taking a bath
full of very serious unless it's done by
jellyfish it is odd such a weird choice
and I couldn't believe it was happening
as it was happening I couldn't believe
it was happening either watching that
entire movie I was like my favorite
thing about seven pounds is watching it
freshly break Spencer's head every time
he thinks about it well collateral
beauty is the one that really watching
this one drama it's a complicated social
metaphor that explores what it means to
be human
we're gonna titty bar gunfight dive
sorry sorry couldn't keep it in there
blending tired fantasy tropes with tired
buddy-cop tropes to explore a world of
racial allegories where orcs are
stand-ins for the historical
mistreatment of black people and that's
pretty much it
orcs are black people and one of them to
the cop you know if you're a cop first
pork first if the movie has anything
else to say
I guess it's that Mexicans are scary and
it's like David Ayer classic
yeah this ain't get out now you've never
seen a premise this interesting gets so
squandered where all of the creative
possibilities of a fantasy world being
part of our own for 2,000 years
everything turned out exactly the same
no seriously
our history is the same Mexicans
thuggish businesses are the same we're
in a stolen Toyota Corolla even our pop
culture didn't change take your fat
Shrek looking ass back to Fiona
how does Shrek still exist is it a
documentary there's dragons flying
around but our buildings never changed
our cop doing they never even mentioned
that you can't just add the word magic
and claim it's any different from a
normal cop movie magic task force the
Alamos I remember watching it when I saw
it the Alamo thing was the thing that I
tagged it on to I was like because I
kept expecting them to like be like this
is 50 years in the future and 30 years
ago like some crazy thing happened like
alien wheel opened someone made a wish
over a copy of I said The Silmarillion
or whatever yeah they woke up yeah work
showed up at some yeah like alien but
like no so then when I realized oh this
is the world and and it just happened in
parallel but when he said the Alamo I
was like wait was it where orcs at the
Alamo but no but he's but no so that so
but what was Davy Jones Davy Crockett an
orc yeah or was David David Davy Jones
and David let's go in was he an orc who
yeah orcs how did the existence of
dragons affect the western expansion
with English colonialism do you ride it
drag it can you okay I have the most
questions I have is about horse cop not
about orc cop but horse cop when they
saw a flash horse cop because the whole
movie is also centaur you're being
really excuse me centaur cop the fact
that this whole movie is about the
integration of an orc into the police
force a nonhuman into the cop world and
then they just show you
centaur cop right there there's centaur
and never mentioned never like well you
know it worked we had some trouble with
the Centaurs but now like now okay
several questions
wait go back bring back bring back does
he have a partner who gets to write that
is the most important centaur it now
because cops you see them on horseback
when they're doing like crowd control
and they get to like ride up above and
like pretend you know that they're
Cowboys or whatever to guard the outdoor
mall yeah does does anyone ride horse
centaur cop why would you throw
something in there a nonhuman cop in the
movie that's all about the troubles of
having a nonhuman cop
yeah please for and also like we've seen
the cop locker room is there a special
locker room for 16 notes notes I want
you guys and everyone at home to do
yourself a favor
search for Chris Parnell Christopher
Walken's since there's a schedule right
now is interviewing to be a doctor at
Christopher Walken is interviewing him
and he's like asked him two questions
about being a doctor and then he just
starts asking him centaur questions and
he's like are you gonna get back to me
being a doctor and he's like no the rest
of the interview will be since hard
questions like can I ride you like how
do they wipe their butt
yes it's amazing and it gets really but
yes I feel like that was in parallel to
that scene because if you saw the back
end of a horse and didn't know if it was
a horse or a lady centaur would you be
attracted to it was a horse yeah go see
it but I agree like it does kind of it's
also better than right yeah I'm just
unless there's a whole other cultural
stand-in for centaurs that we are really
gonna learn later on or that was cut
like why centaurs are trustworthy but
orcs or not I was thinking centaurs are
like trusty Finn's Norwegians I don't
know like I don't know the particular
racial prejudices of these this Police
Department other than orc cops or
perhaps are bad or potentially bad
because if like it's so weird that it
was a they specifically made it a 2,000
year old grudge like it wasn't like like
something from the civil rights movement
or something like that but it was
something I did 2000 years ago that'd be
like us like getting
really pissed off at like Pharisees
looking really mad about I don't know
Etruscans yeah it just don't bring your
trust into this Spencer it's so it's so
lazy and that's because if you had done
a movie worried like what does Gondor
look like in 2018 I'd watch it I'd watch
that it's really interesting to me but
when it's just I don't know it's LA and
one of the buildings looks just a little
more Elfi yeah it started with flora the
Rings and like crept that towards the
modern day as opposed to yeah the modern
day anyways that's why we have all this
equals coming so possible summit Jon's
best rate that my critics for either
being to woke or not woken us everybody
wasted the whole premise of a modern day
fantasy world none of which will matter
to Netflix because with an infinite
amount of money you can greenlight an
infinite amount of stupid ideas to keep
an infinite number of people from ever
going to a theater again well we had a
good run movies now to never leave the
house starring Will Smith the door for
Cobb the filth element and Orlando doom
and also starring the following bright
sequels we write for significantly less
than three million dollars to reporters
track down a story but one of them is a
Balrog which means she's Filipino a
mild-mannered vampire inherits a coffee
shop but there's a twist vampires are
Guatemalan gremlin and frost giant but
he's at you know that one that could be
my luck yeah there's a tag line on that
one
what sort of the re1 Minch nine realms
I've a
oh she's alright she's okay
come on everyone clap if you believe
that was a John improv yeah take right
there was a rhythm from the epic just
riffing yeah off the top of the dome and
then we came up with which you will now
see in our deleted scenes okay I haven't
seen this I'll be like the viewer
because with an infinite amount of money
you can bankroll an infinite amount of
ideas to keep an infinite number of
idiots distracted oh sorry I'm at magic
idiots probably edible Salk a waste of a
perfectly good joel edgerton true elf 11
a MacGuffin doe or cop true cop bad cop
screw gonna crash with orgs albright
this is utopia can we hit pause on
movies written by white guys that turn
races into different species well you
heard earlier in this video on from the
ashes and I will laugh and then you'll
explode and kill all your friends right
problem solved give them the wand or cup
source and them soar deep bond aha deep
up in five buddy
again something that happens in normal
Los Angeles all the time that's true yes
there's definitely almost people
speaking in dead in the ocean or in Orca
tongue or something close to it yeah
well I hate this movie so much
yeah Joe was not I think Joe is probably
the most doubt on this I think that it
wasn't like just a soul-killing but it
was exactly was the waste of potential
it was like this could have been a fresh
take on fantasy but it wasn't I'm just I
don't know I I get sad for and tired of
like people dying on the hill of movies
like this cuz it's like wait like anyone
who's like you did you get it bright was
great it was really good it's like no
wasn't just be okay was saying that it
wasn't don't love it because again I
think that this is probably something
that if it's like your first buddy cop
movie like one's an orc and one's loose
math you love how are they going
get together I mean if you love David
Ayer then you'll love this movie I guess
because it literally recycles every
David Ayer plot beat he's done right up
to one of the cops saves kid kid turns
out to be directly related to gangster
that is about to kill cop yeah they did
that yeah yeah that's training day it's
all one crazy night like one crazy night
no no all of David Ayres movies are like
even Suicide Squad yeah this is when one
crazy day do you like do you like boring
magic ladies menacing your heroes he's
done that yeah yeah God get some new
moves
get some new moves training day is a
great movie yeah he wrote that he wrote
it he wrote directed yeah no but he
wrote it great movie Dark Blues a great
movie yeah I like to end of watch I hear
end of watches really guy enjoyed end of
watch his last to not not for me not for
me well we're gonna get a chance to get
ever more bright because they've already
moved for in the sequel because it was a
huge deal for Netflix so I hope they
could take frost giant as a Jew yeah I
really hope they reach out to us
Hey yeah it's cold in here yeah all
right well you'll be back at beers I
will be posting that spec script later
on screen junkies Twitter and you will
be coming back here next week where we
will be covering oh yeah there's a lot
of hmm this will be a different one are
we symmetrical right now the way we're
sitting get you got some font ready
punch okay yeah there you go there's
your clue and we'll see you back then
for one of our weirder honest trailers
onto the next episode of honest trailer
commentaries yes
you
[Music]